norma cuevas never thought she would
become a pro-abortion activist
she lives in a poor and conservative
community in the province of santa fe
but her life changed when her teenage
daughter who was pregnant
was diagnosed with cancer in her jawbone
she was one month pregnant and i told
the doctor why don't you do an abortion
because she has three children
but they said no that a judge needed to
get involved
my daughter needed chemotherapy and no
one wanted to help her
ana maria sebedo was 19 when she died
doctors kept her in a hospital until she
gave birth
so she could begin the treatment but the
tumor almost covered her entire face
neither she nor the baby survived
they said they would do an ethical
meeting while we waited on the streets
with my grandchildren
and i was pushing them so that they
would begin treatment the ethical
meeting was with priests
i wanted to save my daughter
abortion is legal in argentina in cases
of rape or if a woman's life
is at risk it finds lots of resistance
when it comes to implementing the law
especially
in places like this one where poor women
have almost no resources to fight for
their rights
as the senate gets ready to vote on
legalizing abortion
stories like those of norma cuevas and
her daughter show how entrenched
anti-abortion culture is in argentina's
most remote regions
in spite of this health authorities say
at least half a million irregular
abortions happen
every year and many women end up in a
hospital because of complications
[Music]
and that's one of the reasons why
pro-abortion activists have been taken
to the streets for years
wearing the collar green the symbol of
their campaign
early in december the lower house of
congress approved a bill
which would allow interruption of
pregnancies until the 14th week
the senate vote is expected to be closed
close
the senate is much more conservative and
we know this
we're very conscious of this we also
know that last year there was an
election
that renewed the legislative chambers
and so there are more senators willing
to make
history and settle this debt to
democracy that we have
with 3 200 women who've died in
democracy
and for all of us who are still alive
and all future generations to come
but the debate has polarized society
that has close ties with the catholic
church
pope francis is argentinian and has been
lobbying against the law
[Music]
anything can happen with the result of
this vote because we have a president
who is taking it upon himself to
demonstrate the worst of corrupt
politics
which is to go to his own party
politicians and ask them to vote
even though they may be opposed a
president who is showing no mercy with
this law
because he thinks it will be his
administrative victory and his
end-of-year victory
a victory that people like norma cuevas
hope
will guarantee what happened to her
daughter will not happen
to anyone else teresa al jazeera santa
fe
argentina